في وقعه غريبه اختفى لاعب منتخب مصر
المصارعه بعد تحقيق الميداليه الفضيه فما
القصه
فوجئت بعثه منتخب مصر المصارعه الموجوده
في تونس حاليا باختفاء لاعب المنتخب احمد
فؤاد مخدوده واللي بيبلغ من العمر 22 سنه
من مقر اقامه البعثه وده بعد تتويجه بفضيه
بطوله افريقيا للمصارعه
تبين ان اللاعب ساب كل اغراضه في غرفته
بشكل طبيعي وساب كمان ملابس قديمه عليها
فيما اكتشفت البعثه غيابه واختفائه واغلاق
هاتفه بعد محاوله التواصل معه وفق اعضاء
البعثه فان اللاعب يمتلك تاشيره دخول دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتاكد هروبه وسفره الى
فرنسا
وضح والد اللاعب من خلال مداخله في احد
البرامج التلفزيونيه ان ابنه تعرض لضغوط
شديده وانه مش هارب ووضح انه بيشتغل سواق
توكتوك وانه بيجمع كل الفلوس علشان تطلع
ابنه بطل وانه رباه على حب الوطن وانه ما
كانش يعرف ان ابنه هيسافر فرنسا ولا ابنه
كان عنده النيه دي ولكن دفعته المعامله
السيئه والتقصير من جانب الاتحاد فيما يخص
عدم حصوله على اي اتعاب ماليه لمده سنه
كامله مستكمل والده ان بعد فوزه ومكافاه
الميداليه الفضيه المقدره ب 16 الف جنيه
تم خصم 12 الف جنيه منهم كضرائب
ووضحت مصلحه الضرائب المصريه الجدل مؤكده
انه تم التواصل مع الاتحاد المصري
للمصارعه ونقلت رد الاتحاد بان اللاعب
يتقاضى شهريا 3000 جنيه وبيتم خصم 10%
ضريبه كسب عمل وتلاته في الميه رسم تنميه
طبقا لقوانين الدوله وان الخصم من
مستحقاته تم بسبب الرسوم المطلوبه منه
لانتقاله من مركز شباب بيلا للانضمام
للمشروع القومي الموهبه واللي تقدر ب 13
الف جنيه كان مطلوب من اللاعب سددها قبل
الانتقال ولكن تم تاجيلها لحين حصوله على
مستحقاته للتيسير عليه فتم خصمها بشكل
تلقائي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وضح رئيس الاتحاد المصري للمصارعه ان
الاتحاد خاطب الاتحاد الدولي وسيتم مخاطبه
فرنسا وان هيكون في تدخل من رئيس الاتحاد
الافريقي من خلال الكونجرس القادم في
اجتماع الاتحاد الدولي موضحا ان اللاعب لا
يستطيع اللعب مع المنتخب الفرنسي الى بعد
اربع سنوات يحصل على الجنسيه ثم يخاطب
الاتحاد الفرنسي نظير المصري الا ليحاء
القبول او الرفض على حد قوله واشار رئيس
الاتحاد المصري للمصارعه ان بامكان
الاتحاد ايقاف اللاعب لافتا الى ان
الاتحاد الدولي ممكن يمنعه من المشاركه في
اي بطولات في المستقبل
وزير الشباب والرياضه الدكتور اشرف صبحي
باجراء تحقيق حول هروب لاعب المصارعه احمد
بخدوده ايه اللي حصل على فضيه بطوله
افريقيا وده بسبب وقوع حوادث هروب ممثله
لعدد من اللاعبين في المنتخب ففي وقت سابق
هرب محمد عصام فتحي لاعب المنتخب المصري
للمصارعه تحت سن 17 في شهر اغسطس الماضي
وسط الهجوم الحاد على اللاعب المصري وجه
رجل الاعمال نجيب ساويرس رساله لاحمد
بخدوده عبر حسابه بموقع تويتر فكتب ارجع
وانا هصلح كل اللي ضايقك احنا ولاد بلدك
وعايزينك
الازمه تدخل الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي لاعاده اللاعب في السياق ده وجهت
الاكاديميه الوطنيه للتدريب بناء على
توجيهات الرئيس السيسي دعوه للاعب
المصارعه احمد فؤاد بغدوده لتلقي من حاله
تدريب والتاهيل مع رعايه ماليه كموهبه
رياضيه مصريه واعده